hello true health seeker and welcome to
another exciting episode of the learn
true health podcast today I'm
interviewing my hero dr. Joel Wallach he
is the reason why I no longer have type
2 diabetes chronic adrenal fatigue and
polycystic ovarian syndrome and
infertility and why my husband I
naturally conceived our son after 6
years of trying his approach to natural
medicine and healing the body with the
90 essential nutrients is absolutely
revolutionary but also comes from years
and years of research I'm so excited for
you to hear his information every time I
hear him I learn more and more and I've
been following him he's been mentoring
me since 2011 and learning from him is
it is such a trip because he regularly
helps people reverse diseases even to
the point where they're on heart
transplant list kidney transplant lists
they're on their deathbed I've seen him
help people who were told by their
doctors that they just needed to go home
and die that there was nothing left for
them
I've seen him reverse so many diseases
and help people get back to 100% health
so I'm very excited for you to learn
from him today now if you'd like to as
you're listening if you'd like to buy
the supplements that he has developed
and he recommends please go to take your
supplements calm that's take your
supplements calm you fill out the form
and a health coach that's trained in dr.
Wallach protocols will help you pick out
the right supplements for you based on
your symptoms your nutritional needs and
based on the dr. Wallach protocol that
would best suit you the body responds so
quickly when you fill in the nutrient
deficiencies when you fill in those gaps
where your diet has been missing certain
key minerals especially trace minerals
because it's so hard to secure all of
the 90 essential nutrients in a diet no
matter how healthy we eat and that's
something that dr. Wallach addresses in
today's interview so go to take your
supplements calm and try dr. Wallach
protocol I have seen the most amazing
results
in less than 30 days people say they
have better energy more mental clarity
and better sleep but beyond that
people's blood sugar stabilizes their
mood stabilizes blood pressure
stabilizes
I have seen people reverse conditions I
had a friend who had a essential tremor
his hands shook his entire life and that
went away within days I another friend
who had skin tags over his whole body
the skin tags fell off I have known
several men reverse erectile dysfunction
with his protocol so he has protocols
for filling in the nutrient deficiencies
filling in those nutrient gaps in our in
our diet supporting every cell in the
body with the 90 essential nutrients and
eliminating certain foods that harm the
body so that we can optimize health at
any age and at any weight it's the whole
program is actually designed based on
body weight so you're making sure you're
getting the right supplements for you at
the right dosage for what your body
needs I really look forward to hearing
from you as you're on the protocol if
you'd like to share with me how it's
going for you you can email me ashley at
learn true health calm you can also join
the Facebook group and share with us
there there's already some listeners who
have shared their incredible experiences
by adding these supplements to their
life now you can't add supplement a bad
diet you can't add supplement unhealthy
habits right we have to focus on a
holistic way of life meaning you have to
look at every aspect of life but we also
can't exercise any healthy and only do
those two things and expect optimal
health because if we have a nutrient
deficiency even in a healthy diet our
body is still missing something so this
is one of the key components to optimal
health is supplementing to make sure
that we don't have nutrient deficiency
and we have to make sure that our
supplements are high quality that
they're bioavailable the body can absorb
them and utilize them and that they're
plant-derived that they're not
chemically man-made and that's all the
things that take your supplements calm
provides awesome thank you so much for
being a listener I'm really excited for
you to hear today's interview especially
because dr. Wallach
hero i I've been wanting to interview
him for years and our schedules aligned
and so just became the perfect time for
me to have him on the show and I hope to
have him on the show again in the future
I also recommend reading his books
they're amazing
please check out his books the links to
his books will be in the show notes of
today's podcast I learned Gerald com
awesome have yourself an excellent rest
of your day and enjoy today's interview
welcome to the learn true health podcast
I'm your host Ashley team this is
episode 435 I am so excited to have dr.
Wallach on the show today
you have been my biggest hero in the
holistic health space because of you I
no longer suffer from diabetes chronic
adrenal fatigue polycystic ovarian
syndrome and infertility because of you
I was able to conceive naturally our son
who's healthy and he's five years old
and you're the one that got me so
excited about health that I started my
podcast four years ago we have over
seven million downloads and over 430
interviews well thank you for the kind
testimony what I'm excited about is that
you're here today to share with all of
my listeners that are wanting to seek
true health and you're here to share
with them what I learned from you two to
end disease in my life and I and I'm so
excited that they're gonna learn from
you today how they can end disease and
how they can reverse and prevent disease
so welcome to the show well again thank
you so very very much Ashley and
appreciate your hospitality dr. Wallach
I love your story can you tell us a
little bit about your research that led
you to discover the cause and cure for
nine hundred diseases well make a long
story short when I graduated high school
okay I'm leaving out my personal stuff
which will take 15 20 minutes so when I
graduated high school in 1958 I already
knew that the medical system was in the
wrong direction because I grew up in a
farm and we didn't have any of the
diseases that in the farm animals that
people had because we were giving
supplements animals that prevented and
reversed those diseases we didn't have
any health and
pterence for them so is much more
economical to prevent and reverse them
with supplements than it was to wait
until they got sick and then call a
veterinarian and paid a veterinary and
go broke and sell your farm so when I
graduated high school in 1958 I went to
agricultural school because I wanted to
get a degree in agriculture and halfway
through that I found try for veterinary
medicine so got into veterinary school
and I was working part time because I
had to work my way through didn't have a
lot of money so I had to work my way
through and was working part time for
the pathology department and realized
there were so many many things that were
so simple but people weren't being told
the whole truth and so in 1964 I
graduated University of Missouri I had
my degree in agriculture my major was an
animal husbandry nutrition I minors and
peeled crops and soils I got had my
veterinary degree at the time and I was
halfway through my degree in pathology
so I was going to Iowa State University
names I would have finished my degree in
pathology well as a high school kid I
had worked with Marlon Perkins my old
new to Omaha Kingdom show because I was
a farm kid and didn't mind throwing
manure out of stalls of animals in the
zoo and stuff like that and he kind of
followed me a little bit and he wrote me
a letter said look well like I need you
to go to Africa for a couple years and
work on the white rhino conservation
project when it's over you come back and
get you back into graduate school if
that's what you wanted to get a job in
the zoo whatever you want can't refuse
Marlin Perkins from new Schulman whole
Wild Kingdom
so went to Africa and two years into it
I had caught 200 white rhino and shipped
him back here so if you see a white
rhino in a wild animal park or zoo it's
either one that I caught her offsprings
and one that caught the time there's
only 470 left the southern raised a
white rhino south of the Zambezi River
today there's 25,000 because of the game
parks we established and trained people
and caught the animals up north and
brought them and put them in the Ranger
parks and stuff like that it's very very
proud of that
so two years into that I was prepared to
stay in Africa forever actually I was
having the time of my life living out in
the bush you know eating wild antelope
and and stuff like that and fish and and
just work on conservation projects but I
came back here at again Perkins
invitation says look Wallach
your work when you were doing your
pathology stuff I got a twenty five
million dollar grant using your kind of
research papers and I want you to come
back be the pathologist on this project
we got this twenty five million grant
this is was he April of 1967 and I don't
know if it will be two years or five
years or ten years or what but I need
you to be a pathologist I'm going to
find the diseases that are caused by
pollution that zoo animals are sensitive
to in the big cities and people who live
around the zoos are sensitive to so when
there's people when the zoo animals
start dying from the pollution we know
to evacuate the city so I want you to do
it can't refuse Martin Perkins so I came
back April 1967 to be a pathologist on
the project make long story short
ten-year project I did twenty thousand
autopsies it was um seventeen thousand
some change of over four hundred fifty
four species zoo animals in three
thousand humans 20 million chemistry's
and I learned and published in a book
which is my thesis of this whole project
the thesis represents the seventeen
thousand autopsies in these four hundred
four species of animals eight thousand
human autopsies or in another book
called epigenetics but anyway to make a
long story short what I found out was
there none of the zoo animals died of
pollution none of the human beings
living within a ten-mile raised of the
zoo's data pollution there were no
gently transmitted diseases there were
no particularly transmitted birth
defects I mean was driving everybody
crazy and so that's how all this started
I when that was over I went to work at
the primate Center in Yerkes Family
Center from with NASA in Atlanta Georgia
and worked at the medical school there
was pathologists at Grady Memorial
Hospital and in Atlanta Georgia and ran
into the first non-human case of cystic
fibrosis proved that it was not genetic
got it published and they fired me
because everybody knew psittacosis was
the disease that's a classic example of
a gently transmitted disease as well I
purposely saved tissue and blood and all
kinds of stuff so you can do your own
look yourself and see if your results
match mine now you're part that's when I
went back to school became a nature
panic physician in Portland Oregon 1978
was teaching for seven years pathology
and clinical medicine graduated in 1982
and been treating people nutritionally
for something like nine hundred
different diseases using nutrients for
72 years when you discovered that cystic
fibrosis in the rhesus monkey was not
genetically transferred but was it was
caused by something else
what was it caused by and why were you
fired okay well first of all I sent two
tissues on the slide delivering the
pancreas in the lungs to experts in city
of roses and the big children's
hospitals around the world ten of them
and they all sent back a little note
saying this is a perfect example of
Suzuka BOCES thank you I didn't tell
them it was from a monkey but I had it
all on their letterhead okay so I then
put together my paper and brought it to
the powers that be at Yerkes primate
center and also at the Medical School in
Atlanta Georgia and they were so which
they say involved with genetics there's
still our medical doctors everything's a
genetic disease right so back then they
they didn't want to be embarrassed and
so they fired me it was easier to fire
me because I was just a veterinarian at
the time it wasn't I was an innate retic
decision yet and so no just a
veterinarian and so they fired me to
save their faces is what it amounted to
and then a couple years later I found
the contravention cure of most curiosity
gave that to Jerry Lewis and he got so
excited cause they gave 100 charts to
kids that I had cured with most history
Krueger was in genetic simple
nutritional deficiency he took it to the
most risky association they fired him
and stopped the telethon as I haven't
heard anything about most earnest fears
to the grosses since 1978 and then April
16 2013 my most recent thing April 16
2013 a federal judge
ruled because we kept pushing the
federal courts put this nutrient baby
formula because sedima death syndrome it
was a big lie only two percent of the
babies had died of sediment syndrome
were in bed with their mothers when they
died 90% were not none of them
suffocated you redo the autopsy could
tell they didn't suffocate they died
from what we call hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease and I have
done 1,700 autopsies on kids in an age
of 10 that died of that when in Keshawn
prom in China called Keeshond disease
the deficiency of a single nutrient
causes a sudden heart attack in these
kids and I did 1,700 autopsies in six
weeks and so I'm an expert in that so I
knew that was that's what was causing
because 200 of them would have been
diagnosed with centimeters and roam here
United States got it all written up the
usual process and nobody wanted it
nobody would publish it and so I went to
the federal courts and said look here's
1700 autopsies proving what I'm saying
they couldn't resist
the evidence of 1,700 autopsy all the
slides all the blood and so they ruled
that every manufacturer of baby formula
had to put this nutrient in the baby
farmers three months later let me take
that back it was a year later okay it
was September 13 2014 just about a year
later the Charlotte Observer which is
the big newspaper in Charlotte North
Carolina kind of like the New York Times
for New York front-page story I mean
this was front-page story big bold
letters like third world war starting
they said we don't know why but sedna
death syndrome has vanished in North
Carolina oh my god three months later
the state of Missouri did the same thing
their headlines in their newspapers
three months later every newspaper in
America said we don't know why the death
rate from cinnamon nest syndrome has
dropped significantly by 85 to 95
percent in all states because we put
that one nutrient the baby farm you
haven't heard any more about sentiment
death syndrome because it's gone it was
a deficiency of a single nutrient so I'm
the guy who figured out the cause
prevention cure of Citicorp BOCES most
risky and I'm the guy that figured out
the cause and Prevention
of crib debt have you experienced
pushback from the pharmaceutical
industry this is obviously going to
affect their profits well see what
happens is every time I get interviewed
they come along want to have their words
you know say that I'm a quack and all
this kind of stuff there's no proof well
I don't know 1700 autopsies published
through all all the slides and lab dad
and everything that seems pretty much
like a hard prove to me and when I did
the when I was working at the Yerkes
primate Center for NASA when I got
confirmation that that one monkey had
the classic symptoms of psychosis I got
permission to do most people don't know
this but I got permission to do biopsies
of liver and pancreas lungs of the 34
other baby monkeys okay in the same
colony all different mothers and fathers
not related in any way shape or form
other than they were monkeys and they
all were positive forces a corrosive so
I knew it was an environmental thing and
it turned out that the gal who was in
charge of that colony
she was a psychiatrist and she was doing
nutritional studies and that colony were
all these 25 or 30 pairs of these
monkeys unrelated to each other we're
having babies for her research and she
was giving him different nutrients and
she wasn't giving him the standard
monkey pellets so he was feeding him
mixed grains and her idea what vitamins
and minerals were and so that's why they
all got physical roses because they had
nutrient deficiency that's correct it
was just a simple nutritional deficiency
artificially created because they
weren't given the monkey pellets and of
course her and her husband was in charge
of the facility so he's the guy who
fired me because he didn't want her
embarrassed what in humans in utero what
diseases are nutrient deficiencies like
everyone knows that folic acid or full
eight causes neuro tube defects yes
Oh see here's the deal mother some birth
defects are caused by measles in the
embryo early on right
salud amide which was a drug the
prescription drug for morning sickness
would be
given to women early in pregnancy and
that caused 10,000 American babies be
born without arms and legs there's that
but there is no genetic defects anymore
because there aren't any genetic defects
all other birth defects and here's the
experiment that proved it to most people
I was working at the Brookfield Zoo in
Chicago a pair of wild caught arctic
foxes they weren't related to different
parts of the Arctic they were but they
were put together as a pair in the
Brookfield Zoo they got to be little
reader of age you know they went into
season and they got pregnant and had ten
babies and all ten babies were born with
cleft palates and the keepers called me
because I'm doing the pathology up at
the zoo Hospital he said look we've got
ten baby foxes with a genetic defect I
said all to myself yeah and what is it
all day our barn with the cleft palate
the mothers and fathers were going to we
want you to give them the needle with a
drug to kill them because we can have
annals for babies in the zoo that have
Genet defects it can only be perfect in
a zoo as we'll bring them up let me see
him so they brought me the babies and I
say okay look we're not going to kill
these babies because this is not a
genetic defect is a simple nutritional
deficiency during pregnancy what did you
feed the mother and father well they're
meat eaters so we gave them horse meat
and they said okay did you give any
vitamins minerals and other meters a
game horse meat so that's why they got
this cleft palate because this is a
defect of a single mineral okay which is
not found in horse meat if you give them
the horse livers it would been okay but
that the hardest meat okay and so what I
want you to do is feed these babies with
a puppy formula spent for Arvin puppies
I want you to give the mother and father
just dog food and in six months time
when these babies all come to be you
know they're going to come into heat and
seasons all that kind of stuff at six
months of age and so I want you to put
one son with the mother one daughter
with the father and the other brothers
and sisters match them up so we're going
to really do some super inbreeding here
I want the mothers and fathers right now
to start getting dog food the babies are
going to get this infant formula for you
know milk replacer for puppies that are
orphans and when they get to be six
weeks
you're going to want solid food give
them dog food well a year later they
call me I said okay doc we have between
all these things we put together here we
have a hundred babies from these two
foxes many of them have cleft palate
nope they're all perfect so I proved my
point didn't I say yes you did so I said
I don't want any more of these animals
out there being fed jizz horse meat they
got to get vitamins and minerals if it's
appropriate wolves and coyotes and you
know if foxes they need you know dog
food and then there's camp food for the
small cats and we'll figure out a diet
and supplement program for the big cats
okay and so that's that was published in
scientific journals it's a big story in
the book rare-earth win cures it's a big
story in the book dead doctors don't lie
it's big a story and some of my books
with the pictures of many of these baby
foxes with the cleft palates and so you
know all the way I've been able to prove
what I'm saying and so now when I go on
you know like an interview someplace the
doctors will call up and make a big
hoo-ha well you know this guy's a quack
and you can't prove what he's saying a
blob of lysis well how come his thesis
is in the Smithsonian Institute is a
national treasure they hang up you know
respond to that now you talked about
curing case Sean's disease in China can
you tell us the story of case Sean's
disease and how you came to cure it
okay well Keshawn disease is again a
deficiency of the single mineral causes
is sudden hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
heart disease 25,000 American kids died
of that every year here under the age of
20 is the sudden heart death that
afflicts young athletes in their teens
and early 20s you hear about this all
the time this teenager you know played
football or play soccer played baseball
or hockey or rugby whatever it was or
basketball and drops dead
that's Keshawn disease okay it's not
some mystery okay and if they would be
giving these kids my sports drink which
has 100 nutrients and including that one
mineral okay and give them the 90 cents
of nutrients
guess what none of these 25,000 kids are
died anymore but doctors on the sports
medicine doctor here and we're going to
give them one of these things that have
complete nutrition as you
twenty-seven nutrients in it and it
doesn't have that nutrient at all well
it turns out that my wife's doctor Milan
who is a medical doctor from China well
I'm telling her about all the sudden
heart deaths and she says that sounds
like Keeshond disease is what's that and
so she got me all the the English
versions of publications occasionally
yeah you know looking at the slides and
yeah this is it
so she and her family heaven is still
even yet today have a lot of power in
China this was published in scientific
journals in three languages in 1990 I
did the work in 1989 and it was
published in 1990 in three scientific
journals a two in Chinese one in
Mandarin the other Cantonese the third
one is in English is that called the
Journal of trace element research so if
anybody wants to check it out and see if
I'm lyin they can check it out 1700
autopsies has caused
Keshawn disease aka hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease is caused
by in fact there was some famous athlete
that just died here and he was in his
20s he just died a couple of days ago
from a heart attack
okay so he was a basketball player or
soccer player or whatever he just died
due to the fishing of a single mineral
people say well tell me what it is tell
me what it is to know you'll try and run
you can't run to Walgreens anymore
because they're shutting down but you
run this stuff someplace and try and buy
it and you'll give it to somebody and
they'll die because they will Wallach
lied no because there are cofactors
necessary for that one nutrient to work
just like when people get out she
approached the doctor say oh you have a
calcium deficiency take some tums
that's the doctors way to deal with
osteoporosis is take tums because it has
some calcium carbonate well let's see
what else did your bones needs besides
calcium vitamin d3 sulfur magnesium
copper phosphorus are you getting the
picture hmm you definitely you need you
need the the full complement you need
doctors exactly and so this is why you
have to appreciate Ashley you know
there's only one prescription class of
prescription drugs and cures anything
and that's antibiotics and advice will
kill bacteria
and some fungus okay
but guess what all other prescription
drugs are purposely designed to treat
symptoms well I had so much pain from my
arthritis for ten years my doctor gave
me the opioids in three minutes time my
pain was gone I just loved my doctor and
then two years later sorry Francine your
disease kept progressing here even
though you don't have any pain now it's
time you have to have a double knee
replacement is going to cost $50,000 per
knee it's a good thing you have
insurance and so the doctor is able to
send his two kids to college with that
mineral deficiency that led to the
osteoporosis is affecting every soft
tissue as well in all other organs and
creating negative symptoms as well
symptoms that doctors will write off as
normal oh you have sleep problems oh you
have restless legs
oh that's normal here let me give you a
drug for that that's correct and they
send their kid to college with the money
but there are a lot of good MDS out
there with really big hearts that really
do want to help people the problem is
they're not they're not trained in
anything that you've discovered they you
discovered that these nutrient
deficiencies are the cause of these
diseases and that you've published this
and I've seen you regularly reverse
diseases and even to the point where
you've saved people from amputation and
save people from being on the
heart-transplant list and kidney
transplant list you've reversed heart
disease kidney disease you've reversed
diabetes and save people from England
actually we do this all the time we take
people who've been a diabetic for 30
years and 30 days you're not a diabetic
we take people who've been on kidney
dialysis six days a week they have not
urinated in ten years and in two weeks
time they're urinating and six weeks
time they're off as Alice's because
these are all simple nutritional
deficiency disease we change your diet
we put them on the 90s in solutions with
the secret sauces for their particular
disease it all goes away I have a new
book out it's on the 25 diseases of the
skull when you have honesty approach to
the scholars 25 different diseases that
you would go to a neurologist far and
have surgery to put implants in your
middle ear
and you know you have all kinds of eye
surgeries and back surgeries and neck
surgeries and arm surgeries all kinds of
stuff in fact osteoporosis to the skull
causes atrial fibrillation you ever
heard atrial fibrillation yes it's a
squeezing of the 10th grade or the vagus
nerve which controls the rate and rhythm
of the heart you can also have you
gender of disc disease and the first
four frantic vertebrae squeeze the final
nerves are controlled rate rhythm the
heart so there's two possibilities so I
always feed for both of those and people
have afib and I'm going to tell you
about a congressman from Baltimore
Maryland Elijah Cummings you ever hear
him I have done okay he was a a black
congressman from Baltimore Maryland for
20 years very famous guy okay a leader
in the black caucuses everything else in
the Congress 20 years he gets a fib the
cardiologists take him in anesthetized
him cut him open
take a soldering iron heated up and they
were trying to kill the part of his
heart muscle that was running away you
know sending off these regular heart
beats and they killed him
by doing what's called an ablation time
to kill a part of his heart muscle that
caused his heart to beat irregularly he
to come to me he'd still be alive
because all I would do was fix the
osteoporosis of the skull take the
pressure off that tenth cranial nerve he
wouldn't have had the atrial
fibrillation anymore you're the one that
cured my my husband's afib he was a
candidate for a pacemaker
he was an acute afib for the third time
and you said put CM cream on his back at
gogo to see it obviously continue taking
the supplements the minerals especially
hang upside down an inversion table and
goes to your chiropractor and we
followed your instructions to a tea we
also did like ice packs on his back and
his a feb 8 bent away will be figured
out was he was anytime he lifts heavy
weights he it would compress his his
thoracic spine and he'd develop a fib
and it's a like clockwork yeah what
Hammond was as a sort of a closer
together compressing them they smashed
the roots of those spinal nerves that
control the rate more than the heart
mm-hmm yeah and the cardiologist wanted
to put him put him under and give him
give him a peacemaker yeah well believe
me they would have done an ablation
before they put in the pacemaker you
know which means killed part of the
heart muscle what did the doctors say
when he didn't have a tip anymore
oh we didn't go back to them that's why
your husband's still alive see yeah not
only beautiful you're smart
well we listen to you because you we've
seen you help so many people when we
were just so grateful that we keep
listening to you and learning from you
well thank you passing on the
information absolutely it blows my mind
when one client I had a few years ago
she she came to me for weight loss she
goes I'm sick I'm 25 pounds overweight I
hate being overweight I said well what
happened tell me she was well my doctor
who's my boss because I work at a at a
clinic and I've worked there for 20
years my doctor has me on these steroids
for my adult onset asthma and the asthma
is so bad they have to be on all these
steroids and these steroids cause me to
to gain weight I said wait a second
let's back up dr. Wallach says this this
and this about asthma right we got her
on the 90s central nutrients with extra
iya phase one month later she calls me
up she goes my doctor took me off of all
the meds I have no I don't have any more
asthma but I'm calling because I want to
help my niece who has a DD and my my
other family member who has this my
other family member who is that and and
I said wait a second
you are off all your meds you you've
known your your doctor for 20 years
because he's also your boss you're off
all your meds and in one month and did
he want to know why did he want to know
how and she said no and that's happened
over and over again I've helped other
people like you helped me reverse my
type 2 diabetes I've helped other people
do the same and they're done none of
their doctors want to know how they've
had them on medicine for years like
metformin or insulin and then they
finally get off of it because they're
healthy and the doctors don't want to
know it's just it's it's so outside
their realm it's so far it's not that
simple well see it's a criminal act
they're doing because they don't want if
they know it's all my patients you get
the same result that you did their
income stream was stopped
their beautiful wife would divorce them
to kick all their kids would get kicked
out of school because it can't pay their
tuition anymore and their dog would eat
them so they're just they're just stuck
in this mentality of their training
luckily there are doctors who are
breaking free from that who are becoming
functional medicine practitioners
becoming nature paths and focusing on
nutrition we're keeping her crossed yes
that's why I started youngevity because
I knew that by myself I would not be
able to have a major impact on the world
but this was too much too much good for
too many people so we started a system
you know and the books and things and
CDs and DVDs so forth when the audio
cassette tapes first came out my audio
cassette tape did doctors in line was
the first audio cassette tape to go
viral it did we did I was sitting in the
backseat of my mother's car when I was
about 11 years old in 1991 and my mom my
mom popped it and I think it was at 11
or 12 and my mom popped it in the in the
the tape player of the car and I
listened to your lecture over and over
again and it completely changed my
thinking and my parents had me see a
nature path and we were on we didn't I
didn't know what your name was but I
heard your lecture and I heard how
important all these different nutrients
were and then I found you again I'll
back into 2011 found found you again I
was like oh my gosh this is the doctor
is listening to back when I was a kid
that talked about the importance of
nutrients now I'm sure the questions
come up in listeners minds why can't I
get all of my vitamins and minerals from
food I eat so healthy I eat all kinds of
fruits and vegetables and I don't I
don't eat junk food why can't I just eat
oh I can't I get all my minerals from
food why can't I get all my vitamins
from food okay what if a mechanic were
to say to you don't waste your money by
putting oil in your car dirt from Texas
or Oklahoma in your car it's only ten
cents a quart there's bound to be some
oil in it are we designed to get
nutrients from food why are we where are
we getting nutrient deficient diseases
where did God put the first human being
in the Garden of Eden
edan so why did God pick the Garden of
Eden why didn't he pick Oklahoma why
didn't he pick Maryland why didn't he
pick London okay here's the deal that's
that's the ultimate question you asked
the alternate question - I'm very proud
of you
this is what we learned in the animal
industry because we don't have health
insurance for animals so here's what we
learned well I'll ask you one more
question you'll know the answer when I
ask you this question it is gold found
equally all over the world no it's in
veins it's in ripples spread out
unevenly okay okay it is found in veins
what about what about silver it's found
in veins it's it's it's very hard to
find these precious metals
what about iron if you look at I love it
if you're like up in a plane and you're
flying across the country you can see
sometimes their soil rich in iron is
sometimes there isn't you can see the
different colors okay and so what about
let's see here um what about sulfur yeah
I I don't know I know I think sulfur is
yellow I think that creates like a
yellow tint to the earth but it's not I
mean it's there's no nothing that's
equally or evenly distributed okay
that's you hit it right on the head
there because nutritional minerals did
not occur nutritional minerals there's
not a single one of them that occurs in
a uniform blank around the croci earth
they all occur in veins like chocolate
and chocolate ice cream they all occur
in veins like gold and silver there's
places where people lived along the San
Onofre familiar with that book and the
movie Lost Horizon the original book was
written by James Hilton he was a New
York Times investigative reporter in New
York Times sent him in the early 1930s
they like 1930 1931 they sent him to
China okay he went to the gilt our
glacier all right in the Hansa district
of China which is kind of halfway
between mainland China and also Pakistan
and the long stood people and it was a
debate whether they were 250 years of
age or
361 years of age Wow and so New York
Times these guys they got to be liners
no way so they get their most vicious
aggressive investigative reporter by
name and James Hilton and they send him
there to investigate these people and he
was able to document these ages and he
wrote a report and it was such a
response to the report when New York
Times published it he wrote a novel
called Lost Horizon and he invented the
term shangri-la for this mythical place
where people lived forever it was based
on the true thing from the huns of
people and the guilt are glaciar then
they made a movie out of it it got more
Awards than any other movie ever and
that book launched horizon is still the
best-selling book ever when enough
copies of the book they made a movie
there's kind of same title Lost Horizon
and of course was and the movies about
an airplane crash of tourists in this
place everybody you know is over 200
years of age and so forth and so they
they figured out it has something to do
with the soil and the water and the
descent in the other and so for those
that's the whole gist of the story who
figured out did you figure it out that
it was they were getting minerals in
their water from the glacier or the soil
they figured that out in 1933 and of
course there's been talk of Blue Zones I
know you wrote a book about longevity
that that there are certain zones in the
world like the honza's that live
regularly past a hundred they're active
they're working their farms they're
fishing they're still working and it 150
160 hundred and seventy years of age
because all these newspaper releases you
know in Europe the United States I have
them in my book rares been cures with
these guys in Hunza they're 168 years
old they're out there still working in
their garden don't have any health
problems at all okay you know a well
documented by all the medical hospitals
there in the regions and so forth it's
kind of like the goal of mind of
nutritional minerals in those locations
you understand what I'm saying hmm yeah
there's a lot of talk about for example
olive oil being the reason why those
Italy lives so long you know there's the
peep there's a lot of authors out there
that that write books on longevity and
they've decided the Mediterranean diet
causes people to live a long life most
of these places like like the oka now
Okinawan 's eat a diet that contains
less animal meat for example and so then
they're saying well maybe it's less
animal meat so they're trying to make
correlations but what is the commonality
between all the blue zones that really
makes the difference when it comes to
staving off disease Molokini - volcanic
ash interesting all these places where
people live a long time their water
sources and their fields where they grow
their crops are 20 feet deep volcanic
action is the beginning of time
all of these reefs are attached to all
of these reefs are attached to volcanic
island chains and so why did the reefs
all start dying as we dammed up the
rivers for electricity
okay hydroelectric we blocked the
volcanic ash from going down the rivers
and feeding the allergy which the which
the polyps that make the reefs ate no
more minerals and that's why the reefs
died electricity is the reason that the
reefs all died because they dammed up we
have 1 million actually we have 1
million hydroelectric plants making
electricity and all of them shut off the
food supply - the reason as by the
resize it is not carbon dioxide from
fossil fuel some propose that it's all
of the pesticides or the herbicides that
were because because the or the
environmentalists to have an agenda and
they will say anything they have to do
to get a grant ok
but have you ever heard the scientific
term crap Ola I have not okay
well every place that there was a
successful reef it was always a reef was
attached to a volcanic island chain can
Hawaii ok Malaysia
the Great Barrier Reef in Australia
because all the water that came off that
coast to feed the the algae between the
coast and the Great Barrier Reef were
from the volcanic mountain chain right
there in Queensland so when they put up
the hydroelectric plants there to make
electricity in the three rivers there's
three different rivers they put the dams
in they cut off the food supply to the
Great Barrier Reef and that's why the
Great Barrier Reef is dying if they will
listen to me and six weeks time the
Great Barrier Reef will be back
flourishing so we're basically giving it
we're giving it a mineral deficiency
because we're taking away those minerals
from that area we put out we've shut off
the food supply to the algae which the
reefs ate mm-hmm now the reason why the
carbon dioxide is going up is because
the algae were the things that required
over the eight - the carbon dioxide turn
it into oxygen and carbon chains turn it
into oxygen turn carbon dioxide into
oxygen carbon chains so why aren't the
algae is doing it now the reason is
actually those allergies require 20
nutrients 17 of which are minerals from
the volcanic ash and we shut off the
food supply to those to those algae they
have enough nutrition to live but they
don't have any nutrition to convert the
carbon dioxide to oxygen and carbon
chain that piece is missing because we
cut off that food supply from the
volcanic ash and so I have a process
okay we're going to in fact we actually
have patents on now
we've been working on it where we have
augers they will auger the silt from
behind the dams or around the dams over
the dams through the dams so they will
dump that silt back in the water on the
other side of the dam we don't have to
destroy their electricity we'll just
order it on the other side of the dam
it'll go down and feed the allergy in
the dam and a reason I'll come back
that's amazing so I mean that mirrors
what's happening with us with our own
bodies because you said like energy the
algae can live but they're minerally
deficient they're missing that silt
because of the dams
and so they're there they're running
only at like half 50% function which is
a lot of people are walking around
minerally deficient and not fully
functioning and then they're taking
medication for the symptoms of mineral
deficiency and you can't you can't take
a like it drives me crazy when people
say they have restless leg syndrome
because that's a that's a mineral
deficiency and I get them on your
minerals and within days they're
completely free of those symptoms and
about 12 other symptoms they didn't
realize they were mineral deficiencies
and yet their doctor had them on a ton
of different drugs to to mask these
symptoms the body crying is he had to
pay for their tuitions for college now
[Laughter]
you helped a very famous athlete Theo
Ratliff you helped him to get his get
his career back and and because of that
you developed your sports drink which I
love your sports drink it's it's amazing
it's full of nutrients it's not like
just that sugary water and that is sold
300 nutrients actually 100 nutrients all
other sports drinks are primarily
caffeine and sugar is really integrating
you know like like Red Bull and all the
other sports yeah yeah sugar water but
coloring and your yours is actually a
healthy holistic sports drink we have a
hundred nutrients in there a hundred
nutrients actually 78 minerals so no no
athlete who takes our sports drink is
going to die from that t shun disease
that hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease your story if the arraylist
inspires me so much because of you I've
got to meet Theo his beautiful wife
they're amazing people wonderful couple
yeah they are in historic you tell us a
bit about his story and how you came
because of your supplements and your
program your protocol you helped him to
get his health back end up eating the
famous theory that we know yeah well he
was in his early 20s and he had boner
boner drives and both knees currently
popped off his right hip
Anna Hawkes Carly's pops off his right
hip knee had it it was surgically tacked
down again he also had a fracture in his
left arm and so they said look this
guy's too fragile to play ball he's got
shooting skills the too fragile play pro
ball so they took his contract
away from him it was all in the
newspaper and everything and we had one
of our distributors there in Atlanta
Georgia contact him said hey you need to
let dr. Wallach talk to him so we talked
over the phone he said I'll try anything
so to make a long story short we put him
on our healthy bone and right pack but
we also came up with our rebounders for
stirring for him with all these hundred
nutrients in it got him on a diet came
off all the bad foods including gluten
wheat bran rose to maximize absorption
and in six months time all his problems
were gone and he got his job back at the
Atlanta Hawks and he made thirty million
dollars from the Atlanta Hawks before he
moved on and made another hundred
million dollars with the other teams
amazing amazing I heard a rumor that
other very famous basketball players
were drinking your sports drink even
though they were being sponsored by
Gatorade and other sports drink
companies happen and the fans started to
notice hey the Gator II doesn't have a
color that like that they wanted to know
what these with these sports teams for
drinking do you know what what sports
teams are now using your supplements do
you know those players in all potential
sports teams all Olympic teams there's
players you know maybe in some cases
that the whole team is playing or
drinking our sports drink but there's
just about every serious athlete whether
they're semi-pro Olympic university or
professional they're using our sports
drink because you have such a deep
understanding of where food comes from
the farm understanding soil keeps
playing why is that soil is deplete of
nutrients even more now than it has ever
been in some places the nutrients have
never been there at all
right so they're not depleted they just
was never there now we have fertile
ground and usually and of course you
know the most expensive land and the
land that people love to will to their
kids and so forth was flood plains
because the the silt from the runoff in
the mountains the minerals would get
would be reintroduced every spring
during the floods to the land
but people who owned bottom land always
had healthier cattle healthier lambs
healthier pigs healthier chickens
healthier kids and they were more
successful farmers because their their
yields were like 50% or 75% higher than
those trying to grow food out in the
desert got it mm-hmm
it was the reintroduction reintroduction
from the floods every year of those
minerals in the silt
now what dammed up the rivers
hydroelectric plants shut off the food
supply to these lands that get flooded
every spring the soil doesn't get the
remilitarization every year yeah
the Nile the Nile is a great example of
that yeah because there's I don't know
how many dams are on the Nile so just
like the reefs when you dam up the
rivers for electricity there's 1 million
hydroelectric plants in the world
actually
1 million there's 2 million other dams
there for water conservation and
irrigation 3 million dams standing up
the water well guess what
they shut off the food supply to the
land they shut off the food supply to
the ocean that's where the ocean is
dying because three million dams damming
up the rivers so the food supply shut
off to the ocean and the reefs and the
old bottom land that used to be the
richest all on earth now you have a
product that farmers can use to
remineralize their soil and you've seen
amazing results I've seen amazing
results even those who add the minerals
to their chickens for example or add
them to their cows mm-hmm I've heard
some amazing stories and then of course
the farmlands crops grow stronger
healthier and pest resistant because of
the minerals in the soil it's correct
and of course when they give our
minerals it has 78 minerals in there the
cows produce more milk the same amount
of grain are being fed and of course the
chicken eggs are like 50% bigger and the
hands when their eyes get really big
when they lay those eggs
I love the barrels I put it in my
vegetable garden and I see great
results but I've also met with some
farmers who have used it and they've
done experiments where they put it in
one field but not in the other and you
can see the difference you can see right
where they stopped laying down the
pearls because something about maybe you
can explain it that the the crops grow
stronger but their pest resistant
because they're stronger can you explain
why is that well actually not only pest
resistant let's say you have a nice
couple and they live in Missouri and
they have a kid and this kid he he's 22
years old and he's five foot six and he
you know his thing is playing pool on
Friday nights at the bar but they moved
to Colorado they live downstream from
the mountains and their next son was six
foot seven and plays basketball one kid
is five foot six and other kids at six
foot seven hey mom and dad and that's
not genetic okay as an embryo thing the
embryo got more nutrition and also as
the kid was born as he was growing up he
got more nutrition growing up because
the food there had more minerals in it
and this kid that was raised in Central
Missouri is there can you can you see
that there's parts of the country people
are taller because of the nutrients they
had access to of course and you know we
have to see okay
you know where are some of the tallest
people in America from well they're from
around Denver Colorado in the mountains
that are from Phoenix Arizona down in
the valleys from the mountains in Texas
are famous for tall handsome Cowboys
very interesting there's also a lot of
oil and gold and silver in Texas - you
mean the soil is more mineral rich yeah
because it's all from volcanic stuff in
Texas all the mountain ranges in Texas
you've talked about how we can prevent
and reverse disease by making sure that
we have the 90 essential nutrients the
majority that is minerals what are the
common symptoms of mineral deficiency
what like the people that are walking
around right now it's that they have
mineral deficiency and they don't even
know it okay well you know I give a leg
I'm lecturing to say 300 500 people in a
room and see out of the 500 people 20 of
them will have gray hair or white hair
I know those people have varicose veins
they have aneurysms they have all kinds
of weird stuff going on in their tendons
and ligaments because the same
nutritional deficiency that causes white
hair causes these other diseases
you know breakdown of the elastic fibers
in veins you get varicose veins you get
breakdown of the elastic fibers and
arteries get aneurysms these things
don't just happen our whole family's
died of aneurysms well you live yeah
we've got five generations living in the
same farm anybody supplement no no
they'd laugh at you if you took
supplements we just eat well because we
grow our own food well there you go
grandma in the old days when she felt
like she's had cravings you know granny
whether it's during pregnancy or they
just would have cravings didn't have
pretzels and and potato chips and
chocolate bars and stuff like that 100
years ago my grandma will eat when she
had cravings would ashes out of the wood
stove oh yes what our wood ashes their
minerals little kids would eat wood
ashes other words so little kids to go
eat dirt out of the backyard and the
little ones before they were let loose
but on their own in the backyard you
know they were in their cribs they would
chew on that rail in the crib and so
when they chewed on the crib they called
it cribbing and when the horses were
minerally deficient they joined the top
rail or their stall and because they
were doing with the little kids would do
they called it cribbing just like the
little kids would do well since I put
those minerals in the baby farm list
they don't have to put the fiberglass
shield on the crib rails anymore because
kids aren't eating the rails anymore
since they have our minerals and all the
baby farm oats can you explain why type
2 diabetes is a mineral deficiency sure
because the people who have to have
genovese your decision a single mineral
because that mineral does not occur in
uniform blank around the coast the earth
it occurs in vein
like chalk and chalk reflection occurs
in veins like gold and silver now here's
the deal why does one neighbor not get
diabetes the other neighbor get diabetes
well were they getting approved from one
gets it from the ANP and the other one
gets it from Costco they have different
sources of those nutrients or maybe they
have a brother who has a farm 100 miles
away and that brothers brings them
bushels of food every week okay so
people who are getting a source of those
minerals natural in their food don't get
those diseases if they move away from
there another place where that mineral
is not there is not in the food and the
grocery stores their kids will get those
diseases oh yeah my doctor says delayed
genetics it had to be back in her family
somewhere when I got on your supplements
I had taken supplements before you know
I bought at the grocery store I remember
I bought supplements at Trader Joe's and
I didn't noticed a difference so I I was
very reluctant right cuz I thought oh
you know I've spent money before on
supplements and it didn't work and I'm
you know why is this gonna be a
different but there is a voice in me
that said just go for it just try this I
had hope in me and at the time I had out
of control blood sugar just raging out
of control blood sugar
I was hungry all of the time when we
were driving somewhere like going on an
errand in the other side of town I would
say to my husband pull over at the next
exit and go to the first drive-thru I
have to eat now it was so I was i oh I
cried I would burst into tears I feel
like a prisoner of my own body I was
always hungry my blood sugar was out of
control
I also had chronic fatigue I was
exhausted all the time and I got on your
trace mineral the first thing I did was
I got on your trace memory liquid trace
mineral and I got on the supplement that
helps stabilize blood sugar cuz as the
minerals in it for that and that day I
just taken a few shots of the liquid
mineral and it was 2 p.m. and my husband
turns to me and said you haven't eaten
anything yet today and I burst into
tears because I checked in with my body
and I realized I wasn't hungry cuz I was
always waiting for hunger to eat cuz I
was constantly hungry
that and after just taking a few shots
of the minerals I didn't have any hunger
and it was 2 p.m. and I couldn't believe
it I was just I was bawling my eyes out
and I thought there's something to this
there's something to this and so I kept
taking it and on day 5 now I normally
couldn't wake up till about 11:00 in the
morning I'd be so exhausted all day I
woke up on the fifth fifth day on your
liquid mineral supplements I woke up at
five in the morning
fully wide-awake bright-eyed
bushy-tailed I jumped on top of my
husband I looked him in the eyes and he
says I don't know who you are you're not
the woman I married but I'm keeping you
and I knew that there was something to
this so I called my artoo we called our
two best friends one lives in Toronto
and you were giving a lecture that same
day it just it was like I really believe
it's God divine intervention God God and
came to help because that exact same day
I called her up and I said Kathryn Ann I
have to tell you about something it's
amazing that's happened to me this week
and you have to go see dr. Wallach now
she was in her 50s at the time she had
taken supplements her whole life she
didn't healthy her whole life but she
was born with ichthyosis now do you know
what causes nucleosis well I do now but
back then she was told it was genetic as
she raised her hand and you said I bet
you were told it was genetic and she
said yes because my father has it and my
niece has it and you said that the
doctors were wrong and you told her
exactly what to take now this is back in
2011 you told her exactly what to take
three years later she has zero ik the
OSIS and now she the only remanence is
sometimes she gets slightly dry skin
that's it
that's it now her body was covered in
these giant chunks that would just fall
and fall off her and bleed and that was
the EXCI osis that's it which means like
huge scales but you reversed it and and
that was the most amazing thing because
you proved right there to us that it
wasn't genetic but that her family if
her whole family had a
a specific nutrient deficiency that it
would express in that way and you wrote
a book called epigenetics sharing that
link one family if they had vitamin E
deficiency for example would express in
this way but a different family with
different genetics the genetics would
express and maybe issues with the lungs
for example and that you've shared that
the root is nutrient deficiency not
genetics but genetics express in
different ways when you have nutrient
deficiency okay well here's another
piece to that there's a bottom line here
the thing that that all the family
members have a gluten problem they're
eating gluten oatmeal for breakfast okay
and so they couldn't absorb the nutrient
if they were supplementing with that
nutrient okay they're going to be slow
to respond whereas if they were to get
off of gluten and two weeks time to be
all you know you're gone but dick
theosis psoriasis eczema dermatitis
rosacea and asthma are all caused by the
same deficiency and so when you have a
gluten problem wheat bran around oats
that nutrient is extremely difficult to
absorb and so that's why you see little
kids with asthma and they got skin
problems they got eczema and dermatitis
and psoriasis and they'll also have
bowel pump these same people will have
bowel problems will have irritable bowel
syndrome Crohn's disease diverticulitis
appendicitis they'll have things like
colitis
illy itis you got it all those are the
same disease when you look at them under
the microscope they're only given
different names because at different
locations of major pain and so they're
named by location of pain as opposed to
what it looks like under the microscope
because all those bowel diseases look
the same under the microscope they're
all the same they're the results of
gluten consumption you lose 97 98 99
percent of the absorbent surface your
small intestines so even if you
supplement with that nutrient you're not
going to get a full response ORS can
take you three years to get a response
that might shouldn't take in only two
weeks to get a response so do you
believe 100% of the world should avoid
barley we
notes yeah we brother ah no soul world
should avoid it because that's why 20
million people died in India a hundred
years ago from the Spanish flu that's
why right now Brazil is got the worst
cases of Cova 19 they had a thousand
people died last night in 2,600
excuse me 26,000 new cases in Brazil
last night okay because they're all
eating wheat there's a Indian eating
eating these greens and our immune
health of course and you have to
appreciate and you cannot absorb
nutrients and say you're a
three-year-old kid and you get the Cova
19 virus you get minor common cold
symptoms after 50 60 70 years of eating
wheat bread around oats and now you're
65 75 85 90 and you get the Cova you get
really severe manifestations and even
death so what's the difference well the
difference is over the 30 40 50 years
the people been eating gluten we brought
around notice their intestinal lining
disappeared and even if they're
supplementing they can't absorb
nutrients and so the getting do you know
what the immune system is actually you
know you know the immune systems made
out of white blood cells white blood
cells right or the product of the immune
system the immune system is your bone
marrow so when people you know they get
to be 40 50 60 70 80 90 years old they
was called wall --ax fibrous dysplasia
easily just called fibrous dysplasia
which doctors said was genetic okay
no I'm calling it Wallach fibrous
dysplasia because it's not genetic it's
a simple nutritional deficiency caused
by gluten damaging the small intestine
is not able to absorb the nutrients so
the bone marrow dies can't make white
blood cells anymore to go kill and eat
the virus can't make antibodies go kill
the virus can't make red blood cells so
these people are constantly anemic they
have to have transfusions all the time
in b12 injections
and oh yeah they bleed to death because
it can't make platelets when the 20
million people in India died from the
Spanish flu they all died from
hemorrhaging they didn't die from
pneumonia they all hemorrhage to death
because all their bone marrow was dead
when the virus got him and they couldn't
make platelets and so they all bled to
this 20 million in six months oh my gosh
it took me a lot of redo all those
autopsies to figure it out that's
fascinating
are there cultures that don't eat barley
wheat rye oats and they have stronger
immune systems yes they called they're
called Asians they rice and sweet
potatoes Taiwan only has 23 deaths from
kovin 19 that is not eating when I
learned from you to go to remove barley
we write notes from my from our diet
back in 2011 we did we listened to you
we did exactly what you said although I
don't have celiac a lot of people say oh
I don't have celiac I don't need to do
that well I don't have that either and
I've taken allergy tests I'm not
allergic to it according to an allergy
test but when I removed barley wheat
riah notes from my diet I lost 25 pounds
of water weight my husband lost several
as well he went down to ring sizes and I
went down one and a half ring sizes our
ring started flying off we had them
wedding rings custom-made for us and
they started flying off our hands and we
had to go get them resized back in 2011
and they're still fitting perfectly we
had to go down that many ring sizes from
cutting out barley wheat rye and oats
they it caused that much inflammation
and we have pictures of us before and
after going gluten-free but beyond that
going out free as well we don't need
those four grains because of everything
we learned from you and we're again not
you don't have to be allergic and cuz no
go over an allergy it's not an allergy
allergy no and so what I want everybody
to do if they have any wheat brought or
our oats in their house I need to
package it up in a very nice package and
drop it off as a present for their
doctor
you are so funny
why does barley wheat Ryan oats cause
damage to the gut why does it
mechanically cause damage to the gut
it's actually a chemical a damage okay
it's a chemical damage okay because of
the chemical makeup of the proteins in
those grains rice does not have those
buckwheat does not have those millet
does not have those okay so those grains
are all safe it's kind of interesting
too and you look at covin 19 infections
women have the same infection rate up
until about 25 years of age as men after
25 years of age women almost don't get
coded infections at all and men go up is
it cause of beer-drinking yeah men drink
beer drink beer in college you know but
once they get over 35 years of age you
get a little more sophisticated and they
start drinking vodka they start drinking
wine that kind of stuff right that's too
funny that's true and a lot of women are
avoiding you know those carbs because
they're afraid of carbs yeah several
reasons but the men you know they they
like their beer but if you want to drink
beer drink Asian beer Japanese and
Chinese beer made from rice right so the
most important foods to avoid are the
barley wheat Ryan oats what other foods
have you found that are very detrimental
to our health fried foods turn into
trans fats heterocycle means to cause
cancer cause plaque in your arteries
cholesterol is your best friend
cholesterol does not caused plaque in
your arteries or heart disease
Klaus was your best friend again a
period dr. rocha prescriptions for
cholesterol-lowering drugs package them
up and send them to your doctor I love
you so much I don't want to take these
anymore but resins from away I'm going
to give them to you I please use them I
I just not interested with drugs
alzheimers disease is a cholesterol
deficiency cholesterol deficiency did
not occur before the 1903 s and 40s
prior to that time there is no such
thing as Alan some disease or dementia
but there's eight different dimensions
doctors tend to call them all Allisyn
disease because insurance pays the most
money to treat alessandra disease so
they call all eight dimensions as our
disease so I get the maximum pay okay I
take people you know who let me tell you
great story guys name is ray McGregor
he's still alive and he's kickin butt
but he was in I was actually in Texas
okay in Texas at that time and this ray
McGregor had been in a coma he had quote
Allisyn disease for three years he goes
into a coma he'd been in a coma for
eight years in a nursing home being fed
through a g-tube he's in a coma for
eight years with quote Al's horses so I
put him on our program for anti dementia
including three eggs twice a day with
soft yolks and our DS res capsules and
ultimate in plus and healthy brain and
heart attacks and grinding everything up
twice a day and putting it all through
his g-tube now his daughter did this for
him
in three days time he gets up he thought
he was only asleep one day he gets
dressed goes back to work at the bank
use him but vice-president of the bank
it's been eight years nobody knew who in
heck did who are you and they thought
this is his guys trying to figure out a
weird way to rob the bank and he was
perfectly normal
after just three days on my program
after being three years
cholesterol-lowering drugs of staunton
drugs and then eight years in a coma
being fed just you know these liquid
food replacers getting slowly worse and
worse and worse and worse they thought
his end was coming that's why his
daughter contact or ease or anything we
do as well then try this in three days
time she calls me screaming he's back at
work at the bank I love listening to
your radio show because I hear these
stories because people call in and you
tell them what to do and then they call
in three months later and they tell you
this is what happened and you're like
yeah you'd followed what I said good
keep doing it
but you hear these amazing stories I
believe twice I have heard of senior
citizens growing back a sec
set of adult teeth they lost their teeth
you know they're wearing dentures for a
long time and after getting on your
supplements they regrow in their 70s 80s
90s they regrew a new teeth and that's
because the body now finally had enough
minerals to do that and and I just did
that blows that blows my mind that what
the body can accomplish I love I love
following you listening you know to
everything you do a few years ago when
you were here in my town a woman stood
up crying and said I'm a I'm a nurse
and a month ago I was in a wheelchair
and I thought I would have to give up
nursing because I have MS and I have a
progressive form of MS it doesn't it
doesn't come and go it just it just goes
it's just like I just was on my way out
the door and I had to give up nursing
and then I found dr. Wallach and I got
on his protocol and I'm standing here
today and it was you know 30 days ago I
was in a wheelchair and now I'm standing
here because of because of everything he
does and you'd said that that Ms Lou
Gehrig's disease Parkinson's disease
that they're all the same disease but
just presenting in different parts of
the nervous system can you explain what
you meant by that
well different parts of the nervous is
from do different things actually and so
when you shut one of these different
areas down you get different symptoms
okay and so that's just a simple answer
because each of those areas do different
things and so you shut down the one that
causes you started shaking you start
shaking you shut down a different one
you lose your memory you set down a
different one to get ringing in the ears
shut down a different one you lose all
your strength not a thing and so you
start eating three eggs three times a
day with soft yolks you take your
healthy brain and hard pack and throw in
the d'affaires capsules in the olden
iesson plus synaptic and stay away from
all the bad stuff suddenly now and all
this stuff is in this book it's all in
your head okay because there's 25
different diseases that go away when you
do what I tell you to do and I figure it
might as well put all these head things
and wonderful I love it I'm so excited
for your new book is it out yet or is it
when is it coming oh yeah but no no you
didn't you can buy them today so
take great this little book is going to
change America I'd say within one year's
time this little book will change
America because all these diseases that
neurologists make their living off of
and send their kids to college on are
not going to be here anymore
fascinating and so I'm just so excited I
love that because of you these minerals
and nutrients are now in baby formula
that weren't in baby formula because of
you were reducing sudden infant death
syndrome and we're reducing these
nutrient deficiency cause diseases as
people are waking up now one thing you
say is avoid oil and this is so
controversial so many doctors believe
that we should be drinking liters of
virgin pressed olive oil
why is oil bad for us well the causes
are chemical structure they have what's
called double bonds which are very very
fragile connections between one carbon
to another when you leave them sit out
at room temperature for a couple of
weeks like salad dressing on the tables
and restaurants or maybe and one of
these places where you go go through a
line you know and they have the salad
dressings on there and then there's you
fry in oils you baste in oils you cook
in oil as these simmering oils you grill
in oils and you're oxidizing those
double bonds in the oil turning a minute
was called trans fats heterocycle means
and acrylamide
which are one of the most potent poisons
on earth they cause cancer it caused
plaque in your arteries
cholesterol does not cause plaque in the
arteries cholesterol does not cause
heart disease it's oil the oxidized oil
with either just you keep your salad
dressing sitting on your kitchen table
all the time okay we'll take a couple of
months ford oxidizes if you heat it for
frying or just sauteing okay whether
it's fish or fried potatoes or chicken
our hamburgers or whatever it is you're
putting the oil in you cause
inflammation in the arteries and it
causes plaque in the arteries it's the
oil that caused heated oils or oxidized
oils that cause plaque in the arteries
not cholesterol it's just like when
people were told alzheimers disease
there's nothing to do about it
same principle have you been able to
reverse heart disease people come to you
with with four clogs in the heart for
example or they're on a heart transplant
list have you been able to reverse heart
disease Oh
thousand thousands every day thousands
every day around the world one of the
first recognized heart disease is
congestive heart failure was actually
the terminal event of beriberi one of
those diseases that the old sailors used
to die from is caused by deficiency of a
single vitamin congestive heart failure
which doctors want to give you a heart
transplant bar is a simple deficiency of
one vitamin atrial fibrillation is
caused either by osteoporosis the skull
squeezing the tenth cranial nerve are
you get the general gist disease and the
vertebrae first fourth rancic were
raised squeezing the thoracic first
fourth thoracic nerves from your spinal
cord that control your rate rhythm your
heart okay
then these hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
heart disease is Keshawn diseases sudden
heart deaths in these young athletes and
send them a distant drum all the same
thing they're caused by deficiency of a
single nutrient and in terms of deposits
built up where doctors there's no
cholesterol in plaque there is
no cholesterol in your arteries there
was the biggest wide that medical
doctors have told the world they should
all be put in jail for that every
cardiologist should be put in jail there
is no cholesterol in plaque in your
arteries cholesterol has nothing to do
with plaque in your arteries cholesterol
has nothing to do with heart disease
it's oils I love it what book of yours
could someone read if they want to
understand more about this epigenetic
great it's so exciting to share this
information because I've seen it work
now you recently had sustained an injury
that the doctors wanted to amputate your
foot or they were entertaining the idea
and you were able to save your foot can
you can you tell us what happened
yeah legs up in Canada hey I was in
Toronto and we had just finished a big
one of these shows okay there was a late
at night dark and we're going to cross
this field and
been construction out there and they had
created a sinkhole in this field which
we had crossed hundreds and hundreds of
times over the years and was just like a
golf course no holes nothing like that
and so you know there's seven of us me
in the middle and three beautiful women
on one side and three beautiful women on
the other side we're walking because
they're rolling up the the asphalt in
the parking lot so he couldn't park next
to the meeting place we had to walk
across his field to get to the parking
lot and I stepped in his 8 foot deep
hole and there's rebar in there and this
one foot was all punctured with rebar
and it dislocated the SI joint to the
right side and punctured my left foot
well in three days time that foot looked
like hamburger and and everybody made me
go to the emergency room mr. gurney
murder and his oh my god we're going to
cut your foot office oh you're not I got
dressed and got out of there well my
left foot which had the gangrene in it
and looked like hamburger and rotten
hamburger they were going to amputate it
is perfectly 100 cent normal my right
leg which I had to dislocated SI joint
in is still a half it's a half ounce
shorter than the left leg but there's no
pain there's nothing wrong with it and
you know I use a walker for balance but
I don't need it I you know I walk around
the house 14 times twice a day just for
exercise and I can load and unload
trucks and stand up behind the counter
and deal with people all day just
standing ok and so no problem yeah I'll
have both legs when I die at 300 thank
you better absolutely but you healed so
quickly who did did you change anything
with your did you just continue on the
supplements you always take in the diet
you eat or did you change anything no
the only thing I did was I use our
colloidal silver and squirted colloidal
silver up to puncture wounds in a foot
that I'd stepped on the rebar and has a
gangrenous I just squirted colloidal
silver up in the holes and sprayed it
all over the outside of the foot and in
ten days time it was all healed oh my
gosh I've seen that I've seen that
before where people who are on your
supplements were fully nutri fied
and they go in for a surgery they have
they heal faster much much much faster
than any of the doctors expected because
the body can heal itself when it has all
the all of its resources
well actually doctors make their money
when you have a complication from
surgery oh my gosh why would they want
to avoid complications that's where they
make their most money it's so
disheartening and so frustrating but
that's that's why I do the work I do to
spread this information so that we can
help that's why we love you we
appreciate it my dear friend Jennifer
who has healed some amazing things
herself using your supplements and I
have healed like I've shared we started
a website called take your supplements
calm and we help people to get on your
protocols and follow your protocols to
prevent and reverse disease and become
incredibly healthy like I said I
reversed major issues I was told I'd
never have kids I was able to conceive
naturally and we attributed all to the
work that you do so thank you so much a
dear friend of mine the second person I
called to get on these supplements back
in 2011 was my friend Forrest who had
chronic kidney stones he was in his
early 30s and he was urinating kidney
stones for five months straight unable
to leave the house he was in so much
pain and we got him on your protocol and
the kidney stones immediately stopped
and they've never come back and that you
explained it was a mineral deficiency
and I've seen this over and over and
over again that you reverse regularly
reverse issues why is it that someone
can't just go to the grocery store and
buy some generic supplements why is it
that your supplements are unique and
that your supplements are the most
bioavailable that the body can absorb
and utilize the best okay two reasons
number one they contain all 90 essential
nutrients actually more than that 220
nutrients many of which will be deemed
to be essential later on but they
certainly all our programs we have
programs for 900 in disease they all
contain 200 plus nutrients 90 of which
they were universally agreed
as essential now you see the
advertisements on TV for these vitamin
mineral these multiples if some of them
been around since the Second World War
fact I used to take him as a kid okay
they say complete nutrition order today
complete nutrition 20% discount because
of all the Cove itself 20% discount
complete nutrition you get all 27
nutrients that's not even a third of the
90 27 isn't even 30 the 27 nutrients I
think 14 of them are vitamins and okay
and the others are minerals and so they
don't have anywhere near the 60
essential minerals that you need right
they get like 7 or 6 or 12 or whatever
it is there you go it's just because
their idea of complete nutrition is
totally crazy your protocol has 19 to 90
essential nutrients but you also
formulate it in the way the body can
absorb readily well yeah okay we'll see
we use very unique sources of these
minerals and very unique sources of the
vitamins very unique sources so the
omega-3 essential fatty acids none of
our stuff is the same place any of these
other companies get their nutrients from
most of their nutrients from
manufactured you know they're
manufactured like divide the vitamins
are manufactured okay and so we have
more neutral natural nutrition anybody
else but also there are certain places
on earth where this these types of
minerals occur I mean we're talking
about one deposit and these are places
where everybody lives a long time these
are places where there's volcanic
histories and so the volcanic ashes a
thousand feet deep here and so we buy
the property and we mined this stuff and
is still in the plant farm repeat that
is still in the plant form these
minerals are in plant cells or
organically bound as opposed to just
grinded up like ground-up limestone so
that's why ours are so so absorbable
because they're attached to an organic
molecule proof of the puddings in the
eating by taking your supplements
I've worked with thousands of people
since 2011 and they all notice a
difference everyone within days has more
mental clarity better sleep better
energy and then they start to see those
symptoms go away that the symp the
unwanted symptoms go away and they start
to see better health and I just over and
over and over again so I definitely
encourage listeners to read your books
I'm gonna have all the links to all your
books and the show notes of the podcast
so that they can read your books your
information is phenomenal and I love
that you are you go against the grain
you go against the status quo because
you're showing people the truth and
you're not afraid to show people the
truth so that's why you're my biggest
hero in the health space thank you so
much for coming today and sharing it's
it's been Amin actually you were you
were one of the greatest angels of God
because you're his work I've worked with
so many pastors they actually have a
wonderful DVD in the CD set called
praise the Lord and pass to 90 just just
a 30-second story this Pastor Mike
Freeman up in Baltimore Maryland he went
into a coma when the bird flu went
through five or six years ago up on the
East Coast he was put into one of these
terminal wards with ten other people
were all supposed to be dead before
morning EMAS Lindo you know one of his
great two gals he does all his technical
stuff calls me and says do anything we
do very much so yeah I just take our
jizz her plant minerals just plant
minerals not the flavor bone just to
plant minerals and put a face cloth on
both his legs below his knees and every
15 minutes soak them take a Bible in
there read the Bible to him he's in a
coma in the morning she calls me crying
this is well how Pastor Mike too and she
says well as predicted 10 of the 11 were
dead before morning I says Pastor Mike
got up shaved and he's down at his TV
studio telling the world how God's
minerals saved his life I love that I've
heard that before that putting the
minerals on the skin of people who
couldn't take it orally to absorb it I
love that you know I've had experiences
where I had a like really really bad
sunburn you know to the point where
blisters are coming up and I take your
minerals and I spray it on I put it on
one side of my body not the other just
to just approve
like how quickly it'll heal and the next
day the sunburn where I put the minerals
on is gone and the other side still
burnt so it just really it just works it
really works yes I remember you hearing
it was before I want to thank you
praise Lord and pants to 90 let's do
more great things together love you dear
awesome thank you so much dr. Wallach is
such a pleasure you're welcome back
anytime okay thank you so much I hope
you enjoyed today's interview with dr.
Joel Wallach one of my biggest heroes in
the holistic health space and certainly
my favorite a nature Pathak physician
please go to take your supplements calm
and speak with us about what supplements
are right for you the trace minerals
there one bottle of it is about $24 the
liquid form of 77 trace minerals and
elements so everyone can take it it's
affordable for everyone and then of
course to get all 90 essential nutrients
that's right for you and then as he
mentioned like the secret sauce
depending on your your symptoms and the
your health concerns and your health
goals there are certain packages that
he's created certain protocols and
programs that he's created for everyone
depending on their needs and we'll help
you with that so go to take your
supplements calm and we really look
forward to helping you I've been working
with everyone there take your
supplements calm I'm so excited that you
can be part of it
part of helping get your health back now
if you're all if your health coach and
you're interested in learning how to
help people with supplements we can also
help you there we can there's a whole
training program for health coaches to
learn how to utilize dr. Wallach
protocols to help their clients so we
can help you with that as well awesome
thank you so much for being a listener
thank you so much for sharing this
podcast with those you love remember go
to take your supplements calm and have
yourself a fantastic rest of your day